i don't want to talk about it
this whole thing disgusts me it's sick
and i don't even want to talk about too
bad
arrangements must be made
you're number 999 this is none of your
business venom i'm your father that
means that means nothing don't be
ashamed carnage it happens to all of us
but not ashamed i just don't want any
anything to do with it
push this and i kill you i'll finally do
it maybe if my host had a little more
filial sentiment a little more human
love for his own daddy some of it would
have crossed over to me
as it is i feel nothing but cold empty
contempt
i hate you daddy
good
the relationship between symbiote and
father should by our long tradition be
cold and if need be downright hostile
any other way is beyond comprehension
love between father and child that's
creepy
perverse
unsymbiotic
carnage i've loathed you like a son
now believe me
this thing that's happening you cannot
you cannot run away from it
if i can't stop it being born
i'll kill it before it's a day old
i am the ultimate life form
chaos control
chaos blast
chaos spear
i promise you
revenge
you're going straight to hell
how pathetic
not again
not you again
i determine my own destiny
i'm shadow shadow the hedgehog
if the world chooses to become my enemy
i will fight like i always have
faker i think you're the fake hedgehog
around here you're comparing yourself to
me ha you're not even good enough to be
my fake
you never cease to surprise me blue
hedgehog i would have sworn you went
down with that capsule
the bolivian jungle steamy rank more
humid than a church pew on sunday and
quiet so deathly quiet
duh it's called narration you ignorant
a literary device that allows one to
establish tone exposit information and
pinch it's a lively way to distract a
pack of thieves like yourselves
as a fringe benefit it gives me
something to listen to besides your
blood choked gurgling icky as soon as it
begins the hunt has ended such as the
way of the jungle
unfortunately it's also the way of the
jungle to call in reinforcements thusly
the prey turned predator again becomes
prey praying that the predators are in
pursuit are as poor with projectiles as
their presently pulverized pals
what i wouldn't give to be marlon
perkins right now
or at least get the power and my
freaking fragged teleporter back online
i swear if weasel took the batteries out
of my suit to run his game boy again i'm
gonna super mario's butt into a body
cast
trees don't go playing mamas don't go
playing nothing found in nature goes
playing which means
we are officially hip deep in the smelly
stuff like pop quiz hot shot
your nose to knee with fireball xl5
thunderbird super duper set of titanium
underoos what do you do dude what do you
do
first thing i do keanu is grab sandra
bullock and hightail it off the bus let
the rest burn
then we build ourselves a little love
nest outside of hollywood scratch that
outside of pocoyma and we spend the rest
of our days baking brownies and
beheading the ever-present paparazzi
it'd never last sanders probably more of
a gun girl than a blade babe and i do so
enjoy running with sharp objects
remember the alamo the bee gees the
difference between natural and modified
20
a whole bunch of quotes from the golden
girls and that 4chan is where the devil
makes potty
everything else just comes and goes in
bits and pieces and some of it doesn't
even feel like it belongs in my head
none of this is real but it's also real
we're inside a comic book but to us it's
full on 3d reality
once my tv didn't work so i kicked it
and it started working again
rorschach's journal october 12 1985
dog carcass and alley this morning tire
tread on birth stomach
this city's afraid of me
i have seen its true face
the streets are extended gutters and the
gutters are full of blood and when the
drains finally scab over
all the vermin will drown
the accumulated filth of all their sex
and murder will foam up about their
wastes and all the [ __ ] and
politicians will look up and shout
save us
and i'll look down and whisper
no
they had a chance all of them
they could have followed in the
footsteps of good men
like my father
or president truman decent men
who believed in a day's work for a day's
pay
instead they followed the droppings of
lechers and communists and didn't
realize that the trail led all over a
precipice until it was too late
don't tell me they didn't have a choice
now their whole world stands on the
brink staring into the bloody hell
and all these liberals and intellectuals
and smooth talkers and all of a sudden
nobody can think of anything to say
merlot daniel
got hungry help myself to some beans
hope you don't mind
no need fine like this
out of prison so far take a look at this
that's right
human bean juice
badge belonged to the comedian blood too
he's dead
investigated a routine homicide victim
named edward blake
found the costume in blake's wardrobe
seems he was the comedian
somebody threw him out of a window
neither of you a lot of dust
an ordinary burglar kill the comedian
ridiculous
maybe or maybe someone's picking off
costumed heroes
that's what they're saying about me now
that i'm paranoid
the comedian was active for 40 years
men make a lot of enemies in that time
as your friend hollis mason these days
they were both minute men when blake was
16 and mason was the first night owl
that book mason wrote he said some bad
things about the comedian in it
implying nothing just an observation
anyway i thought i'd let you know in
case somebody's gunning for masks
better go now things to do
yes i remember
you used to come here often back when we
were partners
you quit
back to owlship
back to america
evil must be punished
people must be told
of course must protect veidt's new
utopia one more body amongst the
foundations makes little difference
well what are you waiting for
do it
do it
i've defeated you at last the green
goblin has won the only battle that
counts the final battle
but now it's time for us to take a
little journey
you never beat me
those were just accidents do you hear me
accidents you can't rush me now
you'll never escape
spider-man or should i say mr parker
i have your woman up here my friend
i trust you understand what that means
it's quite simple web spinner your
presence in this world has been a source
of constant agony to me
i wish you to leave it
permanently
or else gwen stacy dies
a most chivalrous attitude pity you
won't live long enough to enact it
brush fool your end is near
why be so blind is not to see it
romantic idiot
she was dead before your webbing reached
her
a fall from that height would kill
anyone
before they struck the ground
but for you my friend
death will come more quickly and more
surely than the shock of a sudden fall
he'll be coming soon
i can sense it
once he's dead i'll be free free to
conquer to take what is rightfully mine
they think they can destroy me
that they can crush norman osborne with
their petty finances
a few business reverses what are they to
a man with my power
nothing
nothing
in a matter of hours the world will
cringe before
excellent he comes
no doubt my wall crawling foe expects to
ambush me if so he's a greater fool than
i've imagined
for while he guards the front i shall
exit through the rear and take him from
the side
not quite my impudent friend
the green goblin's weapons are many
all you have are those puny web shooters
my jet flyer you unthinking fool you've
ruined it you'll pay for that action
parker
i promise you you'll pay
that's what i get for resting my eyes
never known anger like this before
not raging
not even burning just colder and colder
by the minute
building inexorably
towards something that has to be
dreams filling in all the wrong goddamn
details
i have to do something about that arm
i hear what they say about me now they
say bullseye took something out of me
prison kicked my ass
now they say i'm not the man i used to
be
they're right
it's times like this i remember a man i
once met in vietnam
he killed 38 men that we knew of
ambushing patrols just south of fubai
he'd hit and run disappear like a ghost
i went into the jungle looking for him
alongside an entire squad of marine
force recon
three days in i was the only one left
alive
i'd been shot twice peppered with
shrapnel
stabbed with [ __ ] covered punchy sticks
infection was setting in i was barely
conscious when i managed to drop a
grenade into his tunnel
he still nearly killed me
even as i ripped his throat out with my
bare hands he tried to drown me in his
own blood
so hot it burned my face his head lawled
to one side
held on by nothing but rage and flaps of
skin
yet still he crawled after me reaching
for me breathing through all of his
bubbling gaping wounds
i had to beat his head into pace before
he finally stopped twitching
i staggered out of that jungle alive
feeling like i'd won
a few years later
as i watched the fall of saigon from my
living room i realized what a fool i'd
been
i think about that man every time i
bleed
each time my bones ache or my body begs
me to let it lie down and die
or i start to run low on rage
it used to be a man like that would have
ruled the world
on his back whole empires would have
been raised
or conquered
i don't pray
but if i did
i pray to him
every goddamn day
[Music]